first on CBS this morning we're going to
take you inside a Ford auto plant that's
being transformed into a ventilator
factory now this is all part of the
effort to boost the nation's supply of
ventilators by this summer before a
potential second wave of the virus Kris
Van Cleave visited the factory it's in
Michigan a state where there are more
than 15,000 reported coronavirus cases
but keep this in mind under testing and
under reporting remain a big issue
nationwide this is a first look inside
the Ford Ross anvil plant in Michigan as
it's converted from making car parts to
making life-saving ventilators Board
expects to start building the devices
like this one this month ramping up to
7200 a week they promise to deliver
50,000 by July 4th helped Ford at mitts
may come too late for cities with an
urgent need for ventilators right now
Ford's Adrian price a lot of people when
they heard the announcement we're like
that's great but why is it America's
automakers are already helping those on
the front lines of the coronavirus fight
Ford is making face shields at a rate of
one every 10 seconds we were there as
they delivered hundreds to first
responders in the Detroit area that will
save not only the lives of our
firefighters and paramedics but the
lives of the public hard made miracle
the effort by Ford and General Motors is
reminiscent of World War two when
Detroit built trucks tanks even planes
the plant where Ford will assemble
ventilators is just down the road from
the airfield where Ford once built b-24
bombers
this week General Motors is validating
its manufacturing process for these
ventilators production starts next week
hundreds of employees will be back at
work and will need to be kept healthy
dr. Jeffrey has is GM's medical director
what's the biggest challenge to running
something like a factory while battling
coronavirus these challenge number one
is making employees feel comfortable
coming back to work because right now
there are no homes it's a safe
environment they can control it this
could be a new normal for American
workers temperature checks at the door
mandatory mask-wearing and workstations
at least six feet apart those stations
will be disinfected before and after
each shift measures aimed at protecting
those who are building devices to help
heal an ailing nation we have to do this
this is vitally important to the
American people and those who are sick
Democratic lawmakers sent a letter to
President Trump March 13th imploring him
to implement the defense production Act
he did that two weeks later ordering GM
to make ventilators but critics say that
whole effort should have started weeks
if not months sooner given the time it
takes to ramp up mass production and the
warnings coming in from overseas about
shortages particularly around ICU beds
and ventilators now starting next week
hundreds if not thousands of these
ventilators will be rolling off the line
first to GM then at Ford the goal of
about 17,000 a week by May Gail all
right Chris another good example of
companies stepping up thank you very
much